I couldn't stop thinking about sticky chicken tenders all day long,
and even though it was way too late to be in the kitchen cooking,
I just couldn't stop thinking about it.
So I decided to make it.
I started off by making my own hot sauce
by combining some Fresno chilies,
garlic, peppercorn,
some white vinegar,
and letting that simmer on the stove until the chilies got soft.
While that was simmering on the stove,
I wanted something fresh to go with it,
so I made a Brussels sprout and apple slaw.
I thinly sliced my Brussels sprouts,
cut my apples into matchsticks,
made a quick Dijon mustard vinaigrette,
combine some mustard,
red wine vinegar,
olive oil, salt,
pepper, and then dressed my salad with it.
I love crispy onions on salad,
so I obviously had to top my slaw with that as well.
I set that aside
and moved on to making the breading for my chicken tenders.
Cracked open some eggs,
season my flour and panko bread crumbs before dipping my chicken,
then the flour,
then the eggs,
then the bread crumbs,
and repeating that before popping that in the oven.
By this time, my peppers were soft,
so I blended them up and then pass them through a strainer,
and our hot sauce was done.
My sticky sauce.
I combined some butter,
the hot sauce,
some brown sugar,
and let that reduce on the stove until it thickened
and I pulled out my chicken drenched in My sauce.
And it was time to plate.
Put my chicken tenders down alongside my slaw.
And this was so good.